ومعنا الان من معبر العوجه نتسنى على
الحدود الاسرائيليه المصريه مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سمري اذا النجوان مع هذه
المعلومات الجديده التي افسعها عنها
الجانب الاسرائيلي كيف يبدو الموقف
نعم هذا جزء من التحقيقات المتواصله ليلى
بخصوص هذا الحدث لكن دعينا بدايه نشير نحن
هنا عند مدخل المعسكر
العسكري عمليا للجيش الاسرائيلي على مقربه
من الحدود المصريه هذا هو المعسكر للجيش
الاقرب ربما بالقرب من معضه معبر نتسانه
باللغه العبريه وهو معبر العوجه على بعد
عده كيلومترات يقع هذا المعبر من هنا لكن
هذا الشارع يعتبر شارع مخصص للمركبات
العسكريه وعلى طول هذا الشارع الذي يربط
بين هذا المعسكر وبين
المعبر هي عمليا الحدود المشتركه بين
الجانب المصري والجانب الاسرائيلي داخل
الخط الاخضر وعلى بعد ربما ثلاثه
كيلومترات فقط من هنا لكننا نمنع من
الوصول الى النقطه تماما
الممر الطوارئ كما قال الجيش الاسرائيلي
الذي دخل منه الجندي المصري
فجر يوم امس ونفذ منه هذه العمليه اذا
نتحدث عن عمليه شكلت صدمه بالنسبه للجانب
الاسرائيلي كانت هناك حاله من الذهول يوم
امس على المستوى الامني والعسكري وعلى
المستوى السياسي ايضا
وحتى هذه اللحظه تستمر التحقيقات من جانب
الجيش الاسرائيلي هذا بالاضافه الى
تحقيقات مشتركه ايضا ميدانيه تجري
بالتعاون كما اعلن على الاقل الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي وقائد اركان هيئه
اركان الجيش هرسيها ليفي يوم امس عن
تحقيقات مشتركه ايضا تجري بالتعاون مع
الجانب المصري للوقوف على حيثيات ما جرى
يوم امس نحن نتحدث عن جندي مصري تمكن من
الدخول عبر ممر لطوارئ فتحه الجيش
الاسرائيلي هناك على طول الحدود الممتده
من تلاقي الحدود مع قطاع غزه وصولا الى
منطقه مدينه ايلات على البحر الاحمر
المتوسط البحر الاحمر عفوا هناك ما لا يقل
عن 250 كيلو متر من الحدود اقيم فيها سياج
امني سياج حدودي
يتميز بان به منظومه كاميرات مراقبه حديثه
جدا متطوره جدا بالاضافه الى مجسات ايضا
تقوم من خلالها يقوم من خلالها الجيش
الاسرائيلي برصد اي حركه تجري على الحدود
ورغم كل هذه التقنيات المتطوره تمكن هذا
الجندي من الدخول
والبقاء داخل الجانب الاسرائيلي من الحدود
على عمق اكثر من كيلو متر ونصف اكثر من
خمس ساعات الى ان تم اكت امره وكان هناك
اشتباك مع الجيش وقتل جنديا اخرا خلال هذا
الاشتباك هناك اسئله عديده تطرحها حاليا
القياده السياسيه والعسكريه والامنيه في
اسرائيل كيف تمكن هذا الجندي من الدخول
كيف لم يتم رصد هذه الحركه عبر المجسات
وعبر الوحدات الخاصه للمراقبه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي المقامه على طول هذه الحدود
وكيف تمكن من البقاء طيله هذا الوقت داخل
الحدود وهذه التحقيقات بطبيعه الحال
ايجابيا لكن العنوان الرئيسي ليلى انه كان
هناك اخفاق وفشل امني وعسكري كبير يتم
دراسه الوضع لكن من جهه اخرى ورغم رفض
الجانب الاسرائيلي على المستوى السياسي
والامني والعسكري
للروايه المصريه التي تتحدث عن مطارده
وملاحقه لمهربي المخدرات الا انه من
الواضح بان هذه التصريحات غالبيه
المسؤولين على راسهم رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نت نياهو يتحدثون بالاساس عن حادث خطير
لكن يصفونه بانه استثنائي ولا يعكس مستوى
التعاون المشترك والتنسيق مع الجانب
المصري وبالتالي هناك محاوله واضحه
لاحتواء الموقف لاحتواء الحدث
للتجنب اي تبعات على العلاقات السياسيه
والامنيه مع مصر شكرا جزيلا لك نجوان على
كل هذه التفاصيل شكرا